john lewis a risqué sa vie à maintes
reprises pour nom de l'égalité raciale
dans les années 60 le militant s'était
engagé dans de multiples actions de
protestation aux côtés de martin luther
king en mars 1965 il a failli succomber
sous les coups de la police à selma dans
son état natal c'était lors d'une marche
contre la discrimination raciale en
compagnie de plusieurs centaines de
militants pacifiques
il avait eu le crâne fracturé fils de
mes tailles est originaire de l'alabama
il était le plus jeune meneur de la
marche sur washington en 1963 au cours
de laquelle martin luther king a
prononcé son fameux discours i have a
dream en 2015 pour célébrer le
cinquantenaire du bloody sunday le
dimanche sanglant il avait repassé le
même fond mais dans la main avec le
président barack obama en 2011 à la
maison blanche barack obama lui avait
même décerner la médaille présidentielle
de la liberté la plus haute distinction
civile américaine à l' annonce de son
décès l'ancien président a twitté peu
d'entre nous vivent pour voir notre
propre langue se développer d'une
manière aussi remarquable est
significative
john lewis l'a fait john lewis ne
méritait pas seulement dans la rue mais
aussi au congrès où il a siégé sans
discontinuer à partir de 1986 la
présidente de la chambre des
représentants nancy pelosi lui avait
même donné le titre de conscience du
congrès il ya quelques mois il marchait
à ses côtés son message d'unité continue
de résonner encore aujourd'hui
malgré son cancer il avait fait son
retour à washington en juin dans la
tourmente suivant la mort de john floyd
pour participer aux mobilisations du
mouvement black light bearer ici gabriel
proulx ados canada montréal